[Musique]
le maire des Clayes-sous-Bois le
président de l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines est le
vice-président délégué aux finances ont
été reçus à Bercy par Gabriel Attal le
ministre des comptes publics en cause la
dégradation de la situation économique
pour les communes dans ce contexte
d'inflation les élus espèrent avoir été
entendus et vont suivre de près
l'évolution de ce dossier la ferme école
graine d'avenir de Magny-les-Hameaux a
officiellement ouvert ses portes en
présence du célèbre chef cuisinier
Thierry Marx établissement où tous les
jeunes de 14 à 20 ans peuvent suivre une
formation sans condition de niveau pour
devenir maraîcher primeur école collège
lycée transport ils étaient tous en
grève suite en appel national de
plusieurs syndicats dans les
revendications une hausse des salaires
face à l'inflation mais aussi une
opposition à la réforme des retraites la
maison Elsa Triolet Aragon à
Saint-Arnoult-en-Yvelines rend hommage
au 40e anniversaire de la disparition de
Louis Aragon de 14h à 23 heures se
succéderont concert spectacle
l'exposition dédicace rencontre et
visite de la Maison des deux célèbres
écrivains la 103e édition de la foire de
Chatou se termine ce week-end il s'agit
de la plus importante et ancienne foire
à la brocante et aux antiquités de
France avec plus de 325 exposants vous
pouvez encore dénicher la perle rare
[Musique]